مسلسل الرعب مستمر زلزال جديد يضرب
المنطقه هو تفاصيل مثول سعد المجرد امام
القضاء الفرنسي بتهمه الاغتصاب وفي قضيه
اغتصاب اخرى وانما في اسبانيا رفض طلب
الافراج عن دانيال بعد تغيير اقواله للمره
الرابعه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد الزلزال القوي اللي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
في سته فبراير صار في حاله هلع كبيره وقلق
شبه دائم خوفا من حدوث زلزال اقوى في
المستقبل القريب خاصه مع كثره التنبؤات
والكلام امس الساعه ثمانيه واربع دقائق
مساء بالتوقيت المحلي سجل جنوب التركي
زلزال جديد بقوه 6.4 درجات وبعده بدقائق
زلزال ثاني بقوه 5.8 درجات وطبعا زاد
الرعب ورجعت فيديوهات لحظه الهلع التمل
للمنصات
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الزلزال ضرب محافظه هاتاي وقتل 6 اشخاص
كمان انهارت مباني من اللي كانت تضررت من
زلزال سته فبراير تركيا اعلنت انه ثلاثه
من الوفيات كانوا اشخاص رجعوا لشققهم
المدمر من الزلزال الاول عشان يجيبوا
مقتنيات لما وقع الزلزال الجديد وانهارت
المباني عليهم وحذرت السلطات الناس من
جديد انه تزور بيوتها
المتهالكه الزلزال الجديد هذا يعتبر هزه
ارتداديه لزلزال سته فبراير وبعده ضربت
المنطقه 90 هزه ارتداديه واحده منها بقوه
5.8 وهذه الهزات شعر فيها مواطنين في
لبنان في سوريا في قبرص كمان الخوذ
البيضاء في حلب اتكلم 150 اصابه بجروح
بسبب الزلزال
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العالم كله ظاهر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
امس الاثنين انطلقت في فرنسا محاكمه
الفنان المغربي سعد المجرد في تهمتي
اغتصاب واعتداء على فتاه اسمها لورا في
2016 الاثنين مثلوا امام المحكمه وادلوا
باقوالهم وتاجلت الجلسه اللي متوقع صدور
حكم فيها يوم الجمعه او كان في صور ومقاطع
لوصول ومغادره سعد وزوجته للمحكمه وكذلك
للمدعي زوجه سعد بن ساندو من البدايه وظهر
هذا واضح ايضا في المقاطع
الواقع بتعود ل 2016 مثل ما قلنا لورا
اللي كانت عشرين سنه وقتها قالت ان قابلت
ورجعت معه الفندق اللي كان فخم في
الشانزليزيه وانه كان تحت او كانت هي تحت
التفير الكحول والكوكايين وانهم شربوا سوا
ورقصوا وبعدين حاول يعتدي عليها وضربها
عده مرات لما قاومته واغتصبها في النهايه
وان بعدها غادرت الغرفه وشافها موظفين
الاوتيل بتبكي وتتالم امام المحكمه امس
سعد انكر التهم وقال انه احترام كبير
للنساء وانه بيستفيد من شهرته لنقل كل ما
هو ايجابي للناس باحترام وقال انه السنوات
الماضيه توتر كبير واكتئاب بسبب الروايه
هذه وانه انتظر سبع سنوات عشان يتكلم عن
القصه هذه اللي سببت له ولاهله الضرر
ومصادر كمان قالت انه قال امام القاضي انه
كان وقتها بيشرب الكحول وبيتعاطى المخدرات
وبين حين واخر وانه الان توقف عن ذلك
لورا الضحيه نقلت انباءنا اجهشت بالبكاء
اول ما شافت سعد في المحكمه وانها دارت
وجهها لما وقف عرف عن نفسه وتكلم امام
القادم اما زوجه سعد فكمان تكلمت امام
المحكمه وقالت انه يساعد تقدم خطبها وهو
في السجن الاحتياطي وانه محبه حنون وانه
تعرفه من سنوات ولا يمكن للشخص اللي تعرفه
يكون عمل ما هو متهم به وقالت انه بيحترم
النساء وانه احيانا كان بيتعاطى المخدرات
وانها بتعلم انه بريء ومصديقته ومقتنعه
بكلامه سعد المجرد امام المحكمه رفض
الحديث عن قضيه اغتصاب اخرى متهم فيها في
امريكا ولما سال ليه غادر امريكا قال كان
عندي مشكله وكان لازم اغادر ولمن سال ايش
هي المشكله قال ما ابغى اتكلم في الموضوع
سعد كان اسمه برز في قضيه اغتصاب في
امريكا في 2010 وبحسب وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه فان الملاحقات ضده اسقطت بعد
تسويه مع الضحيه لم يعلن عن قيمتها وفي
2017 وجهت لو تهمه الاغتصاب من فتاه
فرنسيه مغربيه تعرضت للاعتداء الجنسي
والضرب على يد المغني في الدار البيضاء
عام 2015 وفي 2018 وفي فرنسا في بنت ثانيه
غير لورا اتهمته باغتصابها في مدينه
ووقتها انحبس احتياطي لاشهر واطلق سراحه
وبعدها لكنه اجبر على وضع اسواره
الكترونيه لتتبع تحركاته وفي كلام عن
اتهامات اخرى كمان
طيب معنى من طنجه الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه
حنان عبد الله اهلا فيك معنا حنان حنان
نحن تابعنا هذه القضيه مع بعض من البدايه
من لمن اول مره تم فيها اعتقال سعد المجرد
بعد ما اتهمته الفتاه اول شيء ليش الموضوع
اخذ سبع سنين ليوصل للمحكمه خصوصا انه في
كثير ناس اعتقدوا انه مشاكل سعد تماما
انتهت بما انه بيسافر وبيروح وبيجي يعني
اهلا وسهلا اولا ساره كما قلت يعني تابعنا
هذا الملف مع بعض منذ البدايه وتاخر
القضاء الفرنسي او المحكمه الجنائيه مثلا
الفرنسيه في اعطائها الكلمه الاخيره في
هذا الملف لا تعني بان قضاء او قضيه سعد
المجرد قد انتهت ولا تعني بانه سيعود الى
حياته اليوميه ما يجب على المتلقي ان
يعرفه عن فرنسا من ناحيه القضاء في هذا
الاطار هو انه للاسف في فرنسا المسطره
القضائيه في اطار
يعني العنف والاغتصاب معقده جدا ملفات
عديده لمشاهير
واشخاص في التهنوا في هذا الاطار ما زالت
تاخذ مجراها منذ عشر سنوات وعشرين سنه
تاخرت كثيرا لماذا لانه المحاكم في فرنسا
عندها يعني امور معينه تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
وتحقيقات تاخذ مجرى طويل جدا
والضحايا او والضحيه لا يمثل امام القضاء
الا مره واحده في السنه وبهذا مره واحده
في السنه اذا اردت ان تبث في ملف كملف
اعتداء
من هذا النوع تاخذ سنوات طويله جدا وحتى
اللحظه
سيخرج منها هذه السنه بل ما زال الامر
مستمر طيب وهو في خلال الفتره الماضيه كان
حاصل على اذن من المحكمه
بالسفر
والتحرك يعني طيب ايش نعرف عن اللي دار
داخل المحكمه لانه في تفاصيل كثير تم
تداولها على الانترنت
ما نعرفه وما هو حقيقه هو ان الضحيه لغه
طالبت بمواجهه سعد المجرد وتطالب بان تكون
المحاكمه امام العلن ارادت ان تكون هناك
مواجهه بينها وبينه لانها تقول على فكره
في هذا الاطار اقوال لغه لم تتغير نهائيا
بل ما يحدث في الملف هو انه سعد المجرد
هناك تدبدبات في كلامه يعني في الاول لم
يتحدث
والمحامين اللي كانوا معه منذ البدايه
هو اليوم يقول امام القضاء بانه يحترم
النساء وبانه كذا وكذا ولكن هذه الامور
تدخل في اطار ربما استغلال الملف عاطفيا
حتى يتم البث نهائيا في هذا الامر يجب
تذكير بانه تطالب بان ياخذ القضاء مجراه
ورفضت ما عرض عليها يعني عرض عليها الشك
بمبلغ كبير جدا ورفضته تريد انه 400 الف
يورو هل صحيح
فعلا فعلا هذا المبلغ يعني هو الذي عرض
على لغه انا تحدثت
نحن بنقول من طرف محامي سعد المجردي بمعنى
من طرف نعم اوكي عرض عليها هذا المبلغ ضخم
حتى تتخلى عن القضيه ولكنها لا تريد لانه
ما حدث هي انها بعد ان بعد ان وقع ما وقع
واتهمت سعد المجرد بالاعتداء الجنسي
والاغتصاب وتواصلت معها نساء من المغرب
وخارج المغرب قالوا بانهن تعرضوا للاعتداء
الجنسي من طرف سعد المجرد ما جعل لغه
تطالب بحقها وحق هؤلاء النساء اللواتي لا
يستطيعن ان يتحدثن في العالم العربي عن ما
حدث لهن من طرف سعد المجرد هذول النساء هل
هم طرف في هذه القضيه هل تم استدعائهم
للشهاده مثلا
هناك شهاده من طرف اخذت بعين الاعتبار
لشابه مغربيه يعني لم تظهر المحكمه ولا
حتى ما يحدث وتحقيقات لا اسمها ولكن نعلم
بانها مغربيه هناك قضيه اخرى لفتاه
بلجيكيه تم تسويتها ايضا
بالمال ولكن الفتاه البلجيكيه وين تم
تسويه القضيه من الراقصات التي كانت مع
سعد المجرد في في حفل بتونس وحدث ايضا شيء
من هذا النوع بينهما ولكن تم تسويه الامر
بين هذا غير الامريكي القضيه اللي في
امريكا
والامريكيه تم تسويتها بالمال ايضا ايضا
وتم الاعلان عن هذا الموضوع قبل سنتين
تقريبا
على فكره يعني هناك خصوصيه في هذا الموضوع
لانه سعد المجرد كان حاضر رفقه اصدقاء له
من الخليج كان معزوم عندهم في الجنوب
الفرنسي ما وقع هو كان ممنوع عليه اتذكر
بانه المحامي اللي كان عنده الملف منع
عليه ان يخرج من باريس سعد المجرد ذهب الى
تناول للاسف مخدرات خرج عن السيطره ما
جعله يرتكب بعض الحماقات التي تمكن
الاصدقاء من لمها وجمعها لكن جرائم
ليست لا تعتبر حد الجريمه ولكنها تقريبا
بالنسبه على فكره تعامل المراه الفرنسيه
مع تصرفات الرجل مختلف تماما عما نقوم به
في العالم العربي بمعنى انه اذا قمت بلمس
الاوروبيه او الفرنسيه وهي لم تعطيك حق
انت تلمسها فهذا بالنسبه لها اعتداء هذا
عالمي هذا عالمي الموضوع عربي
عالمي المفروض يكون هذا ما
ما في فرق صراحه في هذا الموضوع طيب
المتوقع الان القضيه مستمره اذا يعني بعد
سلسله القضايا هذه عنده هذه القضيه القضيه
مستمره ايش المتوقع في موضوع الاحكام
مجرد من يعني الحكم عليه تقريبا عشر سنوات
سجنا هنا في او في فرنسا بس قد يحصل على
البراءه ايضا
ليس هناك براءه لن تكون هناك براءه لسعد
المجرد لانه ذكرنا في بدايه قضيه سعد
المجرد خلال تحقيقات الاوليه بان هناك
اعتداء هناك
ثبت الاعتداء الجنسي هناك شهود من الفندق
شاهدوا مع الضحيه بانها كانت نعم نعم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه
المعلومات واكيد طبعا حنتابع هذه القضيه
وبالطبع بس بنذكر انه الفنان سعد لمجرد في
اي وقت حابب يعمل مداخله يوضح فيها اي امر
او يناقض اي امر او او هو مرحب في في اي
وقت له حق الرد كانت معنا من طنجه الصحفيه
المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد رفضت محكمه اسبانيه طلب فريق
الدفاع عن اللعب البرازيلي داني البس
بالافراج عنه وامرت ببقائه في الحبس
الاحتياطي واستمرار التحقيقات دانيال بس
قضيه شغلت الراي العام والاعلام الاسباني
والبرازيلي والعالمي كمان بعد ما اتهمته
باغتصابها في نايت كلوب في برشلونه او قبض
عليه في عشرين يناير وتم حبسه بدون كفاله
وبدانا هنا نسمع اقوال داني اللي تغيرت
روايته اربع مرات للان في الاول قال ما
يعرف البنت وانه كان في النايت كلوب مع
اصحابه بعدين غير كلامه قال يعرفها بس ما
صار شيء معاها ورجع غير اقواله للمره
الثالثه بعد ما الكاميرات المراقبه اظهرت
انه كان في الحمام مع البنت وصار بينهم
شيء هنا قال انه فعلا صار لكن الموضوع كان
برضاها امس عاد طلع بروايه جديده هي
الرابعه وهذه بصراحه جديده يعني فداني انه
البنت هي اللي رمت نفسها عليه وهي اللي
اعتدت عليه وانه هو ساكت من الاول وقبل
اتهاماتها له كان يحميها عموما المحكمه
يبدو ما دخل عليها هذا الكلام ابدا لانه
من ساعات رفض قاضي طلب الافراج عنه
ومحاميين وكانوا طلبوا يفرجوا عنه مقابل
انه يسلم جواز سفره ويلبس اسواره مراقبه
الكترونيه والحجه انه عنده روابط عائليه
داخل اسبانيا لكن المحكمه رفضت والقاضي
قال انه الان في خطر كبير من هروبه وفي
ادله قويه على ارتكابه مخالفات وماديا هو
يقدر يغادر اسبانيا في اي وقت
[موسيقى]
الموضوع الجاي اللي
[ضحك]
الموضوع الجاي اللي رح نحكي عنه يمكن يكون
حلم لكل موظفين العالم من قبل الموضوع ما
هو متحمسني يمكن كلجت طيب المهم في شركه
يمكن كثار يطمحوا يشتغلوا فيها الشركه
هنديه واسمها
وهي شركه تكنولوجيا صغيره نسبيا مقرها
مدينه اندور والشركه بتتبنى قانون بيلزم
موظفيها بمغادره العمل بعد انتهاء الدوام
لا لا بيجبرهم على هذا الشيء القصه ان
عرفت لما واحد من الموظفين نشر على صوره
للرساله اللي بتطلع على شاشه جهازه واجهزه
زملائه وقبل نهايه الدوام بعشر دقائق
الرساله بتقول انه الدوام قرب يخلص
والسيستم راح يعمل شد داون خلال عشر دقايق
قوموا امشوا طبعا الشركه اثاره الانتباه
والاهتمام والكل يجري عليها بيعرف ايش
الشركه ومن اصحابها وكان بيفكروا المديره
هناك قالوا انهم يعوا جيدا اهميه التوازن
بين العمل والحياه الخاصه وانه بيهمهم جدا
موظفينهم يقدروا وقت مع عائلاتهم
انه يوم الزفاف من اسعد ايام العريس
والعروسه بس هذه القاعده يبدو مو عند الكل
بتزبط خصوصا في عريس صيني تحول فرحه
لكابوس فخلال الزفه هو وعروسته
ظهر فجاه 12 فزاره في عين لافته بالاحمر
وساكتين ما بيتكلموا حرف لكن رغم كل هذا
الشيء قلبوا الفرح فوق تحت الفتيات هذول
اتضح انهم حبيبات العريس السابقات
واللافته كان مكتوب عليها نحن عاشقات
شينسون السابقات واليوم سوف ندمرك
تكه حاميل
[موسيقى]
بعد المشهد الرهيب هذا اعترف العريس بانه
تصرف بشكل سيء مع بعض صديقاته السابقات في
الماضي وجرح كثير بنات بس قال انه الان
نضج وتغير واعتذر عن تصرفاته السابقه وقال
انه عروسته وعائلته رافضين يتكلموا معاه
قبل ما يعطيهم تفسير لمشهد الزفاف الغريب
يعني فوق الفضيحه كمان يعني المهم
البهدله العلنيه هذه لكن منصات التواصل
الصينيه صراحه ما تعاطفوا ابدا مع العريس
ولا حتى شويه يعني
[موسيقى]
واحنا بنجهز حلقه اليوم استوقفتنا تغريده
نشرها الزملاء في ثمانيه وعجبتنا مره
ويبدو انهم استوحوها من اللي جالس يصير في
العالم الفتره الاخيره والجدل حول
الكائنات الفضائيه ثمانيه سالوا متابعيهم
انه يعني لو افترضنا صحه وجود الفضائيين
في هذا الكون لماذا قد يزورون الارض برايك
بصراحه الناس تالقت في الردود وفي ردود ما
قدرنا ما نتوقف عندها ونعرضها لكم تفضلوا
عجبتني هذه اللي هي ينقذوا البشر من
انفسهم لهذه الدرجه نحن سيئين مشاهدينا في
امان الله
[موسيقى]